Do you want to get out? Is this a, is this us? Yes, this is okay.
[inaudible]
this is Radiolab. I'm Jad Abumrad.
Since our program today deals with stumbling upon the past in unlikely places,
cause always begin this part of the show,
not at a place we'd normally visit.
So I feel like we're standing on top of a mountain. But how high up are we?
Right here? I believe we're about 180 this by the way, is chief Dennis Diggins.
I'm an assistant chief in the New York City Department of sanitation.
And when he says 180 he means feet at 180 feet high. Wow.
So that's about 18 stories. Correct.
18 stories up into the Staten island sky. That's where we're standing,
where we're standing on the hill, basically like a big dirt hill.
And in a glance,
you'd never know that this hill was made from anything other than dirt.
What did this used to be? Unless of course you dug about a few feet down.
This is all garbage underneath this.
Up until March of 2001 we were taking in all of New York city's garbage.
All the burrows were coming here, all the burrows were coming here.
So we are probably taking in on average 11,000 tons a day.
11,000 tons a day. That's what does 11,000 tons look like.
That's a lot of car Freshkills used to be the biggest empire dominate on the
planet. That's all in the past. You magic with a little engineering help,
it's gotta be a great park. Absolutely. Yes.
We'll be a park and just look at how much property have you told these mounts
are getting wrapped in plastic and covered with grass. There'll be a restaurant.
Can almost imagine that. I've been a golf course. Yeah.
I would love to be the first ones to tee off on that,
but underneath it all the garbage will still be here.
50 years of trash waiting patiently
until someone comes to look for it and someone always does.
I know years ago we hit,
there was a a a garb at arc arc it,
how do I say it, right? Archeological garbage man, the cave here.
And he did some core sampling meeting with a special tool.
This guy bored a hole deep into the center of the Mount,
actually came up with a hotdog landfill 10 years previously.
So hitting the hot dog that's 10 years old and it still a hot dog,
recognizably a hot dog, the hot dog. So that's a,
that's amazing and disgusting.
I still like hotdog so I'll eat it. Seriously.
Do you ever consider the history that's contained in this,
in this big chunk of garbage? Oh yeah.
Well this is one big time capsule time capsule time, capsule time,
capsule time capsule times that time capsule time, capsule time, capsule time,
capsule time capsule you can set up can stop saying that now. Thank you.
I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is radio lab series about science and discovery and that is exactly what we
have for you today. Three detective stories.
And each one begins with a rather peculiar clue clues that leads you back into
the past time capsule time capsule.
And now that we've got that phrase in our minds and garbage as well,
let's go to a different part of the world.
And get things started for real to a different time. Also,
1898 Egypt Oxa Rinkus Egypt. You with me?
Where's Oxa? Rinkus Egypt. It's in the south, in the desert, south of uh,
of Cairo I think. And let me show you a picture.
You see the desert? Oh yeah.
It's a big flat sort of sandy place and he's, who is this guy? Well,
you should see two guys. They are a,
they're two Oxford archeologists with a pit helmet and sort of standing high on
a mountain looking down, you know, one guy is on top of the mountain,
the other guy is toward the bottom that's Grenfell and hunt to Oxford
archeologists.
They were in Egypt in 1898 looking for treasure and they find those sand dunes,
which don't look quite like the other sand dunes really.
They're sort of strange and irregularly shaped,
which is why when they saw those Sandana and you're looking at,
they hired a team of workers and they started to dig
and they immediately began to find them.
It's huge quantity of pottery flows, shoes, baskets, rope.
That's Derrick ob scholar from Oxford.
He tells the story of what they found and what they found was basic.
Typically the mother load a huge circle of rubbish mounds over 20 of them that
were completely undisturbed.
Oh, thought this was no piddly little trash heap that was 50 years old like you
might find in Staten Island. These mounds. Whew. [inaudible].
These were rubbish mounts that had built up over the course of 10 centuries,
10 centuries of trash.
That's a a thousand years of trash. Yeah,
and that included a lot of ancient paper.
That's what they were really interested in.
Any scraps or squirrels they could find,
and one of the first ones that they pulled out of the ground was last sayings of
Jesus. Wow. Oh, that was the first one that they pulled out of the ground.
He who knows the all but fails to know himself,
lacks everything. If they say to you, once of you come, okay,
forget the 10 year old hot dog here. Then we have come from the light.
We have sayings of Jesus which have not been seen,
read or even heard about for almost 2000 years.
A long list of sayings that are not in the canonical books of the Bible.
He who seeks let him not cease seeking until he find this is a different Jesus
than the why in the Bible. It's almost eastern in tone. He says,
heaven is here. The Kingdom of the father is spread out upon the earth.
It's all around us and men do not see it. If we just opened our eyes,
it's a preposterous that today's known as the log fragment
there was buried in the trash. Wow. Anyhow,
the team pulled as much paper as they could from the mounds,
separated out all the shoes and stuff and just took the paper and then they pack
those up into hundreds of boxes and ship them back to here to Oxford.
This is the Sacrad library in Oxford and we're still today 107 years later.
We're going upstairs. We're still today opening those boxes,
pulling out the fragments,
piecing them back together and decipher in them.
This is what 2000 year old papers sounds like
[inaudible]
sounds just like paper and it looks like dried leaves.
Not really much to look at or listen to,
but knowing that it's 2000 years old and theoretically could have been written
on by Jesus himself, that makes it a little more special.
[inaudible]
which is why we visited Oxford England where the dump now lives packed away and
700 boxes of books.
I can tell you about 600 and published with clarity. Nick Ganis,
one of the collections curators popped one open for us.
I'm just opening.
I know official document sometime early the fourth century.
Of course,
it's full of holes probably caused by little worms and there's the sad part.
There are enough secrets in these boxes to rewrite the past.
The problem is much of this is very hopelessly fragmented.
Reading it is almost impossible.
All the fragments, if you see lots of them,
they'd look like and conglomeration of conflicts.
There will be a few hundred years before even the most substantial of these
fragments come to light.
We're talking about the reconstruction of, of works that the work on,
which is beyond the scale of a single human lifetime,
way beyond in the past 107 years.
The Oxford team has to work their way through a whopping 1% of the collection.
They may take another 10 centuries to get through the rest.
Here's how it usually goes. Nick scours the boxes each day finds a new scrap,
tiny little scrap, brings it into the lab for cleaning.
What I do now is remove some Anson mud with the help of a brash
here. He wipes ancient mud from a torn page of Homer's Iliad
after it's mud for each piece is cataloged in the computer for various features
like type of hand write in size
and style
and if the piece seems to match the other pieces,
Dirk and maybe a Grad student spread them all out on a long wooden table and
basically from there it's a classic jigsaw.
How about this when just met with click, these might be the wine beginnings of,
I think there's one here.
I think that that looks like it's promising that to see if the words match up
cause they seem to line up pretty exactly with the lines of the verge of
fragment.
May take five minutes, it may take five years.
We take five lifetimes, but eventually they will have,
well not the whole story, not even a page or the whole story.
Something
I've put the parties on to an electronic microscope.
Maybe just a few Greek words from the deep past host site, punk.
Probably a criterion that the Moose on that whole day and contact about 10
[inaudible] guys.
Uh,
but we miss them a bit from the upper right corner.
Sometimes a sentence breaks off just when you need it to tell you what you need
to know. We have to be satisfied with knowing of little rather than a lot.
Make sure I understand this. Is,
is each of these fragments just a teeny for like is it a to B or it's more like
to, what was that smell? Some of them are tiny, tiny.
I mean there was about a half a million in total,
half a million and a and they've only got through about 5,000. What is it,
do you have in your own list of things like a, a sort of fever hits list? I do,
I do. I've narrowed it down to, uh, to my top three. Okay.
My top three ancient garbage greatest hits, if you will, which is difficult,
but here's three that are really interesting. First number three,
ancient garbage, greatest hits. Number three, you being a death metal fan,
I'm sure are familiar with these three in auspicious number
[inaudible]
absolutely. Six six, six side of the beast. Right.
Just to explain that the number of the beast,
six 66 is what you use to either some of the beast or to keep the beast away
because he can't say his name directly. That would be bad. Yeah.
All this comes from the New Testament. Okay.
Derek showed me a piece of a virus that he found in the dump, um,
about the size of your palm. So what are we looking at?
This looks like there's maybe 30 letters, a copy.
You have to have precisely that passage in the new testament where the number is
stated
that hit them. Who had thought understanding, reckon the number of the beast
for it is a human number.
It's number is hundred and 66 six,
six six which was the traditional number of the bees. Here's the thing,
this little scrap of the pirates,
the Dirk turned up is the earliest known copy that we have of that passage.
He showed me, can we, can you, can you point to the letters again and,
and show me what this three numbers are.
Smack in the center of the pope virus clutters,
Chi Sigma Chi, Yoda,
Sigma Chi Yoda Sigma should say six six, six, right? Yup.
But in fact, Chi, Yoda, sigma, don't say six six, six they don't,
what do they say? Six six one six
no, sort of six six, six. Really? Yeah.
Does that mean all the bibles are wrong or maybe, I mean,
all we really know is that the number of the beast had versions and at six one,
six, maybe the original. Wow.
How long does it take this to filter into the King James Bible or something like
that? It will appear in the next standard edition of the New Testament.
In a note on that page representing as a viable variant that has now appeared in
a proposed Turks.
What does the do biblical scholars except this did they do? Oh, so we all it.
You should just probably be very careful about six blank six from it.
If you weren't worrying about the beast,
well you should probably change your tattoo
shit. All right, let's move on to number two. Garbage.
Greatest hits. Number two, aids. You see the movie tray? Yes.
Do you remember the scene?
Good.
Big, bold, muscular men fighting big, bold,
muscular fights with big bowls and muscular enemies. Huh?
[inaudible]
I know the film and I know how big, bold and muscular.
Yeah.
What did your scrap tell you? Well, they've been very folks recently.
This is big news in the, in the world of the pup biologist,
they got their hands on this special camera.
So we have this digital set up here, a camera on a uh,
on a sort of easel.
This camera uses infrared filters to photograph text.
It's so faded that you can't really see it with the naked eye. Take a
quite a long exposure. In any case,
the first thing that they read with that camera is a poem about the Trojan War.
The new poem of our killer Co's. This poem, [inaudible]F r base,
a pollution straight on Hoyt or [inaudible] comes from the six hundreds,
not homer, it's our silicosis Virginia.
It's precisely not homer because whereas the Homeric version,
the Brad Pitt version, it goes, uh, you know, Greece invade, Troy falls, hurrah.
This version goes Greeks invade, get their butts kicked,
then run, run like sissies
quickly turns to account on
its head.
Wait, wait, wait. It was, so this guy,
this was written at the same time as homely, a little bit later,
but in response to homer, oh
and the great goes like this here,
listen day to tell you crowd one doesn't have to call it weakness and cowardice
having to retreat out at trip.
So there does exist a proper time for flight.
C Homer's notion was that like the hero stands and fights to the end, but,
but this poet was saying, you know what? No, we ran away,
turned our backs to flee quickly and that's okay.
He actually celebrated it as something that he was proud of because sometimes
you had to turn and run.
[inaudible]
running away is a good thing. Running away is a good thing. That's a good one.
See,
what's interesting about the past you find in the trash is that it's messy.
It's complicated. There's not just a story.
You know there's contradictions to that story. Competing accounts of that story,
which can be disconcerting. I mean,
you know who wants to have different bibles floating around.
That can be weird for people, but to me to know that way back when,
even then there were different ideas about what it means to be a hero
[inaudible]
that I find comforting,
which brings us to my first choice. Last but hardly least ancient garbage.
Greatest hit number. Well, the greatest hit.
What do you think people in the first century were reading?
What do I think they were reading?
What do you think they were really reading?
Okay. When the, when the text starts, she's saying, Oh, I'm terribly on fire,
and that goes in Greek day. No s flag of my realm.
A May a K D aw. Say the translation.
Oh, it's thick and big as a roof
and then she goes on a how to make her hard. That's what they were reading.
This filthy satire turned up enough times in this and other dumps for Dirk to
suspect that it may have been a bestseller.
So there was more than one version of this. It appeared over and over and over.
I'm burning, I'm on fire. I'm terribly on fire.
A stream runs over me. Do you understand?
And I'm being a bit [inaudible].
You are listening to radio
from New York public radio,
the U and why
and NPR, right? What?
Keep listening.